there was one that your colleague helped
you with earlier it's now gone no it's
right
okay last speaker M
Ben can you hear
me most of you have heard about this
notion of great thoughts time we were
discussing it with W at much the ideas
you have imposed a discipline on Friday
afternoons after lunch you only think
about great thoughts and I had the
notion that that I and also with you I
think great thoughts about the the
foundations of data
interfaces about radically rethinking
the notion of logical interface to
data Friday afternoon it's
Thursday I'm not Richard Hamming so I
need some kind of
warmup right thinking maybe some trivial
thoughts some maybe mediocre thoughts as
a kind of stretching exercise and so
that's what this talk is I'm going to go
over some projects which I think
will will maybe give the notion of the
goal of rethinking interfaces to data
and that will prime the pump for not
even for questions I won't be at Peak
great thoughts Time by question time but
maybe by tomorrow after I'll be ready
for
great so first I have to explain what I
mean by an interface to data because
this is what I want to
rethink well an interface to data in
general is something you have a class of
users and you want to restrict you have
some Source data and you want to
restrict the the kind of queries for
that class of
users that they can
answer so I'll give some examples of
this later this is
not what you normally think of maybe
this is not even the best way to think
of an interface you normally think of an
interface as maybe a layer like an
antology layer where you have a
different VOC a different data model or
different API that users have but from
the point of view of
expressiveness this is I think you know
one way to think of these interfaces the
bottom line of whatever you give to
users restricted language restrict
different data model is that there's a
limit on what they can ask to the source
data and you can begin
to compare different interfaces this way
you know one person uses this vocabulary
one uses this data model one uses this
semantics if you want to compare them
you'd compare what based on what class
of queries the user can can can extract
what what information they can extract
from The Source database and we'll also
look at this in the setting of multiple
databases autonomous distributed over
the world then an interface will be a
restriction on what users can ask to the
to the global database the union of the
sources but it will have to be to be
compatible with this notion of autonomy
it should be something that factors into
an interface at each source
so there'll be examples later but the
canonical example is traditional
database views say SQL views uh this is
an interface at least based logically on
making some derived data available so
you say well here you class of users
here's the stuff that you're able to see
go wild with any query that you can do
that only uses this data that's a
traditional view database abstractly you
can think of a view-based databases you
have some function on the source
instance or in the case of distributed
views on the source
instances and this function extracts
some data that's the stuff that that a
user can see any query that only uses
that stuff or is answerable based on
that stuff is is the restriction on
queries so I'll use some terminology in
the in the distributed case I'll talk
about distributed views those a
distributed view is just on every local
Source I have some derived data that I I
at least logically export from that that
local source
okay so views can be these arbitrary
functions we'll be interested often in
in classes of views like say CQ views a
CQ a conjunctive query D view is at
every local Source I have a conjunctive
query over the atoms known to that
Source that's what that local data
source is
exploring so the the idea of this great
thoughts exercise is to try and go
beyond views and lots of people people
have gone there before and you you can
begin to think of lots of mechanisms
that have been proposed I mentioned some
of them access patterns this is another
way of
restricting uh what a class of users can
see that's not dve data you say okay you
you need to give this Val a value here
to access this data from and this
functional API that's different from
derived data and then oh so that's
something that's has been studied in in
the database literature Alan Nash and
his colleagues people that Stanford
chenle and Edward Chang Deutch smashan
literature uh views with access patterns
something that hasn't gotten that much
study uh Nash again and his colleagues
uh antoan and some colleagues at Telecom
uh studied this you you say you have
logically some derived data but you
restrict access through traditional
through access method
disciplines various data exchange
virtual data integration mechanisms
there's lots and lots of them in in the
history of databases these can be
thought of from the point of view is
trying to get Beyond views there's an
interesting formalism um from cus do and
no say query
specification pattern language something
like that where you use a restriction an
automaton running over the syntax tree
and you say these are here class of
users here are the things that you're
allowed to to see here's the number of
queries this is going Beyond views they
talk about this as exporting an infinite
class of of use and so this is the kind
of thing I'd like to look at uh I mean
I'll talk about two projects one from a
couple years ago with per Le ja and F
Samora and another that's current work
with with Udi rovski at Oxford that are
in this space of how do we get
mechanisms that go beyond
these okay the first kind of mechanism
uh is this first project it's based on
the notion of minimally informative
query answering uh the notion here is is
we specify a set of queries we call them
in the paper utility queries these are
the things that we want the user to
answer but we don't want to give a
mechanism that just says you can only
ask these five queries we want something
more robust so what we say is well let's
give out the minimally informative
traditional views within a class that
support these queries I'll give an
example in a slide so here this is
something we've also discussed
extensively at lunch dog stool versus
silence computer science conference ET
it's very Theory friendly they they both
have programs with uh different
participants many people here have gone
to both and they have both autonomous
data stores that store the names of
participants which program which year
and they get together and they say we
we're going to create an
interface and we want our interfaces to
support some queries that span the
sources like are there researchers who
are attending uh both programs in the
same
year and you can write this as a
conjunctive query over the the union of
the schemas so it's a join between Simon
participant and Dr
participant and we want a mechanism that
will support this query but give out the
minimal information among distributed
views that will support this join so we
have to formalize this notion of what it
means to support a query and what
minimal information means and I've seen
um coming late to this program but I
seen that a recurrent theme in this
program is information and information
theory in Shannon relative
information we're not going to use any
of that um uh we're GNA do something
less uh less
quantitative uh that I think
is one of the things I'd like to
advertise it's sofen and vu's notion of
determinacy sometimes in in some of Dan
and paris's papers they they emphasize
information theoretic determinacy so it
has a similar feel uh what is
determinacy you you have a query and you
have a bunch of views you say the query
is determined by views if any database
two databases that agree on The View
agree on the query a very simple
definition another way to think of this
is that the query output is a function
of the view
output so we'll say that a distributed
view supports a query if the query is
determined by The View but the way you
want to think of determinacy is you know
information theoretically it's it says
well these views contain all the
information you need for C these views
have more information than C has and the
information theoretic Notions you don't
care about the
computation how complex it is to
reconstruct CU from V1 through VT who
cares V1 through VT have enough
information to answer
you and we'll formalize the notion that
the views are minimally informative
again using S F's notion of dety uh we
say
distributed view is minimally in
informative supporting q u uh within a
class of queries see if if the view
supports the query using determinacy Q
is a function of the views The View has
to be based on queries in C and any
other distributed view V Prime that uses
queries from C it has more information
that means that other view V Prime
determines each view in V so remember
the notion of determinacy if V Prime
determines each view in V that somehow
says V Prime has more information than
each view in v and so this is the
natural way if you accept determinacy is
the notion of information capacity of a
view this is the natural way we say that
that these views are minimal
information so let's go to Simons and
D at least in our minds go to
S uh they wanted to support this
interface uh uh that supports this join
and give the minimal information that
does this it's pretty obvious
intuitively what the minimal information
you need to support this query is you
need to know uh Simons needs to reveal
the name in the year to support this
join because name and year are the join
variables right they cross the join dog
stool also also has to reveal the name
and year and so what Simons should do is
they should publish the projection on
name in here and Doug tool should do the
same give the projection intuitively
that's the minimal information and in
our formalism using determinacy that's
the minimum
information this makes
sense the minimum information is just
true or
false the the answer to the query it's
the minimal it's a static notion it's
minimal this is not instance
determinacy uh it's determinacy over all
instances so that back in their notion
of determinacy it's overall D1 D and D
Prime so it's a static it's a data
independent
notion okay so on a given instance of
course I could say you know the answer
is true or false and so but that minimal
information views are views that will
have the minimal information defined in
terms of instance dependent dependent
independent determin but I can I can
play the same game I just you give me
your instance I'm going to comput the
the The View which is just the answer to
your qu the these are autonomous data
sources the these views the distributed
views are views at each source so I
can't go Simons is not allowed at at
data time at query time to go to dog
tool and say you know tell me whether
tell me what's going on and then export
the data that's this notion of
distributive view says that each each
Source has to do its own thing this
makes sense thank you yeah yeah but you
so I mean it seems in this particular
context you want to be as restrictive as
possible right so the instance level
seems to be what you want to go into and
it could be something like a z knowledge
proof like thing that in a protocol
between Sims and D to right yeah I talk
so so the question about what happens so
okay the first thing is so of course if
you do instance dependent things here
there's also some questions about these
EP epistemic paradoxes you say no I
can't answer
your query because that would be giving
out too too much information but but
okay so so here there's a question about
whether other mechanisms could do more
than these views which is a question
I'll get Toto people looked at right I
mean so so well crypto people have
looked at it and actually well I've
looked at it too in in a couple
slides so
uh okay what what's an example of
results I won't of course address
completely address your question uh in a
couple slides but maybe it be more clear
so in this paper one of the results says
you take any utility query not
necessarily conjunctive query not an SQL
arbitrary function on the global schema
then these minimum of informative devs
exist I'll say a little bit more about
what they look like in a few slides for
CQ utility queries they're expressible
as traditional views in relational
algebra and that we show that the same
holds in the presence of Integrity
constraints on each local Source like
tgds
each so you always have these minimally
informative things and sometimes they're
expressible in relational algebra but
there are CQ utility views where the
minimally informative D views are not
cqs themselves so in you don't they're
not always the obvious ones like in the
previous example I maybe able if we have
time I can give an examp
what can go
wrong we also look within the class of
CQ views say you're committed that
you're you're going to use CQ views
basic SQL queries the set
semantics uh there's for secq utility
queries you have minimally informative
CQ views and these are almost the
obvious ones after you minimize the
utility query they turn out to be the
same as the
obvious so I'll come back to this a
little bit later uh but I wanted to say
what we were doing in this paper the
perspective was uh to analyze the
trade-offs in view design uh you look at
questions of the form are there
distributed views that support this
query but which do not reveal any
information about this other query this
is what we were interested here so back
to Simons and dog stool but making it a
little bit more abstract Simons has a
binary relation
R uh SCH SCH has S&T binary relations
and I'm interested in supporting the
intersection
query well obviously I could support
this uh I could design uh sources to
answer Q each Source just exports its
data all of our all of us all of T but I
want to know well is there some way to
do this while keeping the query there
exists xrxx private we analyze this for
several Notions of privacy but one
notion of privacy would be on no
instance should the attacker be should
external party know whether their exist
xrxx is true
it's sort of a negative version of
privacy that that has been in the
database Theory literature I think it
goes back to Mendelson and a
student uh so intuitively any views that
that support Q uh must disclose p on
some instance uh and okay it's actually
not so this example with no con
Integrity constraints is not so
difficult but using our the prior
results we can compute the minimal
information views show that the minimal
information views disclose this thing
and therefore nothing you can do can
that supports Q there's nothing you can
do that can support q but but make p a
secret that's a a simple case we also uh
well we have several examples where
where the Privacy utility query is less
trivial um here's one of them we look at
the case where there's partial
synchronization
mechanisms uh we look mostly at
replication as a synchronization
mechanism now Simons and dog are not
completely auton autonomous there's a
relation s the relation s that is in the
query is replicated between Simons and
dog but nothing else there's no other
mechanism so obviously they need to
communicate as data updates come in in
order to do this and we have the same
utility query and now we ask the same
question can we support this query while
keeping this their exist xrx private and
the answer now turns out to be yes there
is an there is well I'll put this an
inter face mechanism
actually a view of a certain sort that
can achieve this trade-off it it can
support Q while keeping P completely
secret so this is just meant like what
what were we trying to do in and what
we're what what kinds of results we have
uh we actually have a general result
about what you can do with with certain
kinds of replication in managing these
trade-offs between utility and
seccy so what is the moral I to
give well first you know it's not really
an answer but it's my attempt uh and an
answer you know there we were getting at
the idea of comparing the expressiveness
of different interface
mechanisms so in this case we it was
what can you do with a CQ
view uh versus what can you do with
relational algebra views what can you do
with arbitrary functions I I thought
this is something that is an interesting
direction that I haven't seen much of
and you can look at the same thing with
more interactive method mechanisms we
didn't do it but it's was an obvious
thing is well suppose you have access
methods for instance you can now and now
you can interactively ask multiple
queries can you achieve these other
kinds of
trade-offs and then the second thing I
want to highlight is this notion of of
information theoretic determinacy the
database theorist information Theory you
know uh you know this has been
used you know certainly by a number of
people uh know Paris uh and Dan and
other people at Washington used it in
the pr impressing work uh I've used it
you know in many papers butly on
information disclosure with balder
Pierre other people also KR people at
Oxford I think also Daniel kefer and
some of his work is is this but I don't
think it's really been developed
rigorously and uniformly here you you
have some information lce on view that's
the idea in actually in the pricing work
and in our work and you can begin to
explore
this so I'll come back to this in a in a
a little bit uh but I want to talk now a
little bit what's the idea among this
other work about indistinguishability
this year and it's motivated okay so
first IND distinguish an
indistinguishably relation is just an
equivalence relation on
databases I say here are the two here's
the pairs of databases that are
equivalent and uh this gives an
interface uh uh somebody want is
interacting with the database what is
the queries they could answer well
there's two possible semantics one is
that they can answer any query using the
certain answer semantics and the certain
answer semantics would be well what
they're really seeing is the entire
equivalence class of this database and
they get the intersection of the the
answers over that database there's
another semantics which says oh it's the
answerability semantics they can only
ask queries where the the answer is
invariant under this equivalence
relation so this would be more like
what's called feasibility in Access
patterns or answerability in
views so the main point is you you have
some way of specifying an equivalence
relation I'll talk about some ways you
could specify an equivalence relation
that's giving you an interface and it's
interesting and that it's a it's a way
of giving an interface that's different
from what we're used
to okay you you can of of course think
of this as a view what I'm a view I said
from this General mathema iCal point of
view it's a function on the the instance
or the local instance that support
exports some stuff and you can say what
I'm exporting is the equivalence class
but of course we're representing it
differently let's give you an example uh
the uh I can say G and G Prime are
indistinguishable if they have the same
triangles so uh these are two graph
databases I can say for all X1 X2 X3 ver
they're a triangle in G in database G if
and only if they're a triangle in G
Prime
okay and this uh that's an equivalence
relation it's actually a first order in
distinguishability relation it's given
by a first order sentence in the
language of two copies of the schema so
it's first order not in the sense of of
that we usually say now if you take a t
typical first order sentence in the
language of two schemas it's not going
to Define an equivalence relation this
is a semantic
property uh these things for all X1 X2
X3 and if and only if between G and G
Prime that's going to be an equivalence
relation but you know other things are
not uh so I'm interested in the the
first order sentences in two schemas
that will do
this and I can generalize well the
triangle example is one of them you give
me any relational algebra views they
give a first order indistinguishable
relation the same kind of thing well I
one database satisfies the views that is
the for every Tuple in in the union of
the databases one it's in the view
result in one if it only if it's in the
view result in the other I'm using this
prime notation just like the G and G
Prime to say the Prime copy of the
database agrees with the unprimed copy
on this derived data Michael yeah the
universal quantifiers are they
quantifying over which domain they're
they're they're quantifying over the
union of the active domains
okay so this came up in the prior work
uh I said these minimally informative
dvus exist for arbitrary
utility queries and what how do they
they work actually they're the way we
can present them is as
distinguishability
relation obviously we can show that you
can't always get in very natural cases
you can't get relational algebra but you
can always get this in distinguish
relation presentation actually you know
I think a second order in distinguish
relation and then there was this example
I talked about with replication I I said
well we we could report q without
revealing P how did we do this we needed
some interface mechanism Beyond
relational algebra views we could show
that you couldn't use any generic query
to do this but we Define a simple IND
indistinguishability relation that
actually looks at the data values and we
show that's the way you can achieve this
tradeoff so you can achieve certain
trade-offs with indistinguishability
that you can't achieve with with
traditional
use okay this is a super General notion
we studied this
over mostly over infinite structures
focusing on first order and infinite ter
logic uh but there are few results that
I can uh that I can mention that apply
to the finite case to finite models to
databases um I said that traditional
relational algebra views Give A first
order indistinguishability relation and
you can ask well what other what are the
other first order indistinguishability
relations uh well nested relational
calculus gives you another class of of
first order and distinguish
relations I don't want to explain what
nested data is and nested relational
calculus but I'll explain by example if
I have a binary relation
rxy I want to export all the adjacency
sets of elements in my database all the
this is a set of sets for every element
I take the set of things that are
adjacent to it and then I take the set
of sets by varying the X well that's a
set of sets I can say two two databases
agree on the set of sets in first order
logic in this dual signature rnrp Prime
signature it's for all X there exists X
Prime uh for every node in one there's a
node in the other database that who's
adjacency
setes so in general okay I can do sets
of sets of sets uh uh uh the same way
that's the general idea of nested
relational calculus I build up these
sets of sets of sets you know it's a
different query language and agreement
on a nested relational countless query
gives you a
first
so let me jump since I'm running low on
time to the to the uh the open question
here we have various results about this
but an intriguing open question is is
every first order in distinguish Li be
relation given by Nest
relational we look at the infinite case
where this is not true and we find lots
of phenomenon that go beyond nested
relational calculus and of course we
don't use the word nested relation
Happ it's geared towards a different
audience uh over this is a a
preservation question I have some I have
a first order sentence in the language
of two schemas I impose some semantic
property here's a syntax nested
relational calculus views that enforces
it I want to know if everything that has
the semantic property is enforced by the
syntax okay uh so first I I'll I'll say
this indistinguishable the bottom line
this in indistinguishability relations
they make the world of traditional views
look very small because you can begin to
see lots of other ways
of creating
interfaces uh that are Beyond views and
it gets at the this issue that comes up
often in uh descriptive complexity
Theory and descriptive set theory uh of
going from an equivalence relation to a
canonical representative for instance if
you look at various Notions of
Elementary equivalence like invariable
equivalence you you have a nicely
described equivalence relation you want
to know how efficient it is to export a
representative of this equivalence
relation you have a nice representation
of sort of the dynamic notion you want
to know does that mean that there's a
nice representative you can choose that
representative
concisely so I want to stop now with the
great thoughts stuff if you could give
me a second to do it okay uh
so I want to go back to Great thoughts
and the truth of it is I you know I saw
Mam's talk last week and he gave an
overview of relational databases and it
led to some great
pronouncement you know relational AI is
great by relational Ai and other
profound thoughts and then I saw Joe's
talk and he overviewed relational datab
bases for 50 years and he gave his own
pronouncements morals uh I love Hassel
and uh there's important problems with
synchronization that need to be studied
and Deus is great and I thought I should
have a slide that talks about 50 years
databases and then has some profound
conclusion I couldn't what I want to say
is well in the first 40 years this
notion of logical
interface expanding it uh uh and Notions
of comparing interfaces you find it
relatively often in pods you you know
there's Rick Hull did have some various
things about the notion of information
capacity uh that I I find very
interesting at the at the level of
comparing schemas and then of course
there's been a lot of work over 40 years
at at looking at at funky new ways of
defining interfaces but in the last I'd
say certainly five years not so much so
I think there is some
need to look at this I wouldn't say you
know looking at the work uh in this
Workshop you know I I don't say that
that uh people should stop working on
machine learning and relational algebra
like Zach is and and look about this a
little bit maybe goes a long way and
maybe there was too much of this at one
point but I think going back every few
years and looking at this is a good
thing to do certainly this work has been
very influential outside of
databases thank
you one question and of the
recording do to connection with
differential privacy if you are trying
to hide information from one view you
mention Daniel keeper works
so so we we haven't looked in this I
think this model is just you know I I
shown this stuff to to some people who
work on private say this is ridiculously
restrictive uh which I think is the
right answer I mean our notion of our
notion of that I showed you of of
keeping something secret is a no
instance should the attacker learn the
database which you know is something
that comes in the the database Theory
literature also it's in the KR
literature uh but of course it's
it's in the end differential privacy is
much weaker uh you said that and in
general the the reaction is look you
know I I I don't care that there's some
one database out there in the world it's
mostly used for aggregate queries so if
you have views like non-aggregated views
so the notion is not obvious but
yeah yeah so um first of all very
interesting so I got your framework and
results amazing uh quick question I
didn't get a chance to do justice to the
distinguish Le results but I I can tell
it's not important but can you do
justice to communication complexity have
you looked into this yeah I mean this
this uh so no well not really I mean the
the proofs have a very similar feel to
communication that we're exploiting
autonomy of this and you would think
once we put in some
interaction between the two sources
we're an extreme case of communication
complexity I'd say because there's no
communication between the sources at all
well they both published something and
so they they can compute a few maybe
it's a one round half round I don't know
they looked at all sorts of variations
which I'm not familiar with yeah it's on
my radar to look at I didn't look at
this so like I had a similar question to
S right but right so like yes it's a
differential privacy is a weaker model
because we only have probabilistic
guarantees right um so but your model is
also in another way more expressive
right this indistinguishability Rel
allow me right differential privacy
essentially like a very simple whato
distinguishability Rel but there's still
no probabilities involved even in the
indistinguishability notion right no no
I know right I mean like right your
model is not just stricter but also more
expressive in what we consider to be
distinguishable right yeah well there's
there's I'm I'm mangling two works right
so on the one hand you have this notion
of privacy that's that we give on the
other hand we can be flexible about the
view mechanisms and look at these more
powerful powerful mechanisms right so
I'm so that's true some of it I just
want to make clear that some of this
trade-off is in two different works but
go ahead yes agree right I know that
theability was basically like a query
language for to Define right but it
could also be offici used for
like a privacy mechanism yeah
yeah remember I said that I won't be
ready for great thoughts to tomorrow
afternoon or possibly Monday or maybe
next
week so can you comment a bit about the
complexity of computing is used because
fa is undecided right so so in the in
very easy and you can just compute you
can just so in in the case of CQ utility
queries you don't need to decide
determinacy you can get these minimal
information use
actually
what the for other queries so for other
queries we don't actually know what the
representation is so Pier do you want to
contradict okay so so yeah so actually
so if the if well okay
so well I mean okay so you can get
relational algebra views without doing
minim minimization here
if you want to get the SE so it depends
what format you want the views in you
can
yeah no you you do get the minimal one
you don't just don't have it as a CQ so
it depends on what represent I mean you
know if I've understood your comment
correctly there's two results one it
says Okay I I I can get these relational
algebra views and there we use this this
construction about getting these
shuffles and I think you can do this in
p time it's and it is minimal in
information it's just if you want to
there's another result that says I can
get CQ views and there I need to
minimize the global which is expensive
but
then after you get these minimal views
you have to see whether you can do
disclosure and there we we have some
some results uh on this for the case
without constraints we know how to do it
um I mean we know there you just look at
the minimal at the at this canonical
canonical instance um uh and then with
constraints I don't remember whether we
have complexity B this
yet